meagan Markel is glowing and showing she
looks so great stepping out for a solo
engagement in London
six months pregnant and rocking a ripped
from the runway blazer and v-neck dress
ensemble Megan made her first appearance
today as royal patron since taking over
for the Queen and if those strappy heels
look familiar
they're the ones Megan wore in her
official engagement pics back in 2017
the Duchess visited the National Theatre
in London while Harry was just a few
miles away making an appearance at the
Commonwealth youth roundtable meeting
but his wife and baby do in spring
weren't far from his mind as someone who
is about to become a father I am acutely
aware of our shared responsibility to
make this world more resilient and its
inhabitants more accountable for the
next generation her and Harry are really
happy at the moment they're super
excited about the spring birth of their
baby and I'm told that she's happy
meanwhile rumours that the Duchess might
be back for the ninth and final season
of suits are just that while she spent
seven seasons on the series et has
learned show creators aren't pursuing
Megan for a royal return they can't
she's got royal duties
she's got things to do but I'm sad I'm a
suits fan I know right I want her to
come
you